BLAIR. Or rare rare
rare. Rare.
Rare narrow narrow. Or with
point. Or
whatever. The say
a. Prayer or Larry.
Larry. Or are.
Perfect.
With.
A.
Right. A here.
You're.
With your or. Air. One
hour or. More when the American
who are married with Mary the scenario for
her there or with. Her we.
Are now back. At the rehab object
at the back of the right with
a prayer by. A.
Student small bless it might
sponsor growth. You've got
a good smoker I'm saying that off the
dinner. You like me need a place for
a handout. If you were
over the friendly Well
a what if you ever heard of the belly
mission. If you can get some smoke
and no questions as. To what
we went before Come on past.
Well there it is only put it just like I
told God just and the guy who runs it
is
a soft touch. With. What. I
don't know if.
I have not the soup he's the guy
who runs the joint I'll give you
a crystal introduction she was ready
by the way a form of from oh I'm
a transient Oh OK.
To brother the event that you are not yet
either but that's just like you are very
will come. Here to find food for your body
as well as comfort for you probably mine
. And I had some soup because
of. What happened to them or
not and I just tried it just to say
but they kind of know they. Have.
Their own mind their spending. Like
yeah but I am always doing good. Oh.
I go with
a super mind. Yes. I
take it off. To
the guy that runs this place sure is one
swell guy Yep in most places you go to all
you want to do is save yourself. So when
you realize I'm asking you to leave. Your
body can.
Have another bowl now thanks
to the small. Bites you got.
And I think.
That is that that.
Really was I know I hope you enjoyed
being us. Thank you I'm sorry Mr
You must think I'm somebody else why
don't I have known you and your work for
a long time I tell you I grant you
get your wires crossed them things.
I mean you bring.
That into my private office.
I want to show you something
very interesting.
But about this day that's me what are you
doing with it never mind what you have
going at the moment all right all right so
you know me what's the game. Musta been
that have been used to
be in act before such
a long time. That
is all in the past. They
fancy. That's cut out
of that. Sentence the second
half immediately when Yet I've.
Done.
So. I got the bosses waiting for you to
travel did you bring that package or is not
going to make it up but you promised me I
gotta have it I'll lay on the run down
and as I knew you would let me down
Thanks Greg I think of what that does
a slow death no I didn't I'm
a doctor no doctor my eye.
I would let you treat
a good case. When
you see he said that and I'm sure many
things to the completely. Knowledge.
Trying to get the thought you were still
doing time good to see is what you do on
here that works for me you see and I
need to bring friends to get stronger.
Gotta Know More like there is more demand
you name it for you if you join me now
there's
a publisher. Like you bridge I know I'm
not as quick as I used to be the. These
are still great. Sure we got to crack
a box and I used to be so cool.
Place I took the language is out
of. The news. And there's nobody
like.
What you guys had me come on and go on.
The
Earth's.
The poor
the
you think that. For
a minute I thought I lost the magic touch.
But is a value. Of them. Are
you guys kidding with I talk
a lot. Because I want to know. Please
please don't tell me give me
a chance I only did just control. The
gently trouble. Everything's perfect you
act like it's something bothering you and
you get
a big I told you everything was perfect
we got us well I still say that stuff.
Is
a. Thing as won't bother anybody anymore
you're going to say you got rid of him
without letting me have the body you can't
do that to me. Seems he can do
anything he pleases. Didn't you get
a big enough cut in this last
job. I've been about this.
Thing is was
a good mate is. What stops him from getting
rid of us in the same way I wouldn't do
that. A friend. Set up you know they
help you to talk like that.
These days I'm going to tell
him see what it does today
a couple of little Tried that
you know they're very. I'm
. Not
a good morning to money
loving. Oh I didn't.
Know about feeding the hungry has been
like need earning and I have it I see this
morning. And I give us
a prize for you who. You think your book.
On another person. To
remind you of my love.
Of. The beautiful just like you made it.
With the must have cost me off I
have. Nothing is too good for you.
In the. House in your thought
to give me such expensive gifts
and so on. What better use could I put the
money from I. Should save your money.
Not yours I want you your companionship.
Really. I get so in order for the time. Why
do you have to stay away from me night
after night how much are we going
on like. Maybe. The search for my
new book will be finished
soon and then we go away.
Honestly is it. Odd or nothing
more and they are right nice cool
fresh. Water. Every morning for
three years you start out with the same
stimulating conversation. Sometimes I think
out great. You.
The poor. Old.
Series of robberies is
definitely the work of
a homicidal maniac. Leaving the body of
an accomplice on the job prove that.
So if you. Are the bank full of men are
concerned they better be on their toes
or they'll find themselves
like I don't know. That's all.
Sure let me off they might make you
ever see an Irishman. This is the suit
you start drawing that comes in that's my
go to get up in the history time but of
course it would be nice to be on the
phone without those kids yelling teaches
a class kid. How I love. You know
Mark Some day I'm going to have
a test. But you know you have to
get really first which is. I am
a fire for get that promotion
you loose and you'll be
a detective before you know. When
that happens I'm going to find
a place in the country just like you work
in the garden. You know you have no idea
I'll be in
a detective will have to pitch
they will go. Along Mark. Study
of abnormal psychology recognizes paranoia
as one of the most dangerous types of
insanity perhaps most of them is I'm coming
from the glass why it's so dangerous
Well the patient suffers from delusions
of grandeur he thinks he's very important
way above those around him he has
a superiority complex that's all oh it's
also coupled with the persecution mania
caused by an intense feeling that everyone's
against him so you're connected to him
explained why the chief justice. Well I
guess is because the act the logical way if
you didn't study and you would know it was
now I just. And he doesn't hesitate to
use force to assert his personality. This
leads to an anti-social conduct that Mr
Dennison I think if you
apply the might even enjoy
a life of crime. It's
common my school needs
a wall at the jail but this time the
feet on the over the bridge it is.
The
view
the
of what that which frankly moves.
The mind repeat it up to
him is your promotion.
The
vote
the
you're the
the with
the the world
the the.
I was not uncovered yet
make up much right away.
Holy. I
don't.
I think I mean. I'm sorry Mr
Wagner I didn't mean to disturb
you. I thought I could tell she was
guarding the supplies you need to get
them the goddess because. Those
unfortunates all depend on. You.
I thought you said that right
I'll attend to it once.
And.
The let me take care of it I think. It
might be coming. Let me clean it then.
Don't worry I'm just. Not going.
To. Come on.
Down here.
Either. That I sliced with and
I've got to take my do. Then.
It will seem just
a little bit. There that didn't hurt
much does it don't hurt at all.
That it had. Let me know when you get to.
This. There's my thought since up
there that if you can't read minds.
Take
a look in the pool. And
what can I do for you if your mouth shut.
If it isn't Thank you Ms. To
that you recognize me Mr.
The man have the police after you have
that I not do anything to upset this.
Somebody. I did not say
you. Yes Who is the ass.
Just some old. Seething type.
Beside you make a habit of giving
that there are a lot or just
a precaution otherwise my guess would
be all over the place. Is that
something awful. Happens and I just kill
or live somewhere in the neighborhood is
the get out of the search
always bothered places.
I'd be glad to surely get out myself just
a dog so I believe I see
what you can find of.
The police is looking for someone who
thought they might be hiding kids is
a young fellow by the name of Frank e-mail
about twenty three years old medium
height and dark hair baby face. By
a man of that. He was. I think I
Then he didn't even know where to
go. Thank you. I know about
after you get your eyes off them again not
if I believe that what is needed like
suddenly I'd be happy to cooperate
with the police I'd like.
And. What not. But I can leave now.
I'll be home in about
a month. You
can be like. Friends I'm going. Where
you saw the need for God I have
a proposition that think
you will like. It.
You do make this stuff. This is evidence
that this isn't the mind and the power
mind that might help me. With
this with that just my household.
And I. Then today I do that.
How would you like to join my organization.
One of my associates downstairs
and wanted me to. Help.
I want you to meet Thank you male. Recchi
males are. One of the neighborhoods
public cops. It's my
job. To meddle with him.
You actually. Like it. But you are fair.
Game just because you had what they
needed. It seems we all have our little.
Of it you think you. You wouldn't believe
it's laughable but I am afraid of you.
That's
a hard on glad. I'm afraid of you
because you lost your know. What
I do think. If you want that in
this job you can have it now.
Don't call that man talk to you cross
you like it does everybody else.
But I'm no. Good book thank you.
Gonna do with it should I see.
The catalyst that. I.
Always thought that never
thought I would my anger.
These media groups got I been so sleep so
quite know. That once my past it's like
spackle. Not. All that I thought
I'd do to keep the cats on this
equating my grace. Is with the
outtakes nothing to do. That work.
Just to get. Along but
the guy really got that.
One
a great doctor. He just. Just
a different. But still
a great doctor. And I have proved. I
will say the staff with
a view from the dinner and
you belong in the. Home
any moment now. Always late liking to be
on time just once you know it you know
he's not and is not wrong. With
Melbourne when you're going to put
a stop to all that why can't you stay away
from that place after all if you you're
the one that can make her understand things
and those with their eye surgeon you
can feel her which is more important you
are that Karl or whatever his name is
around that awful place on the
Bowery. I'll try. To do my
dear boy. To make me the
happiest woman in the word.
Duty. Maybe I believe today.
I want to talk to you I
suppose mother will give you talk to you
now that the movie Richard had been
waiting patiently for over
an hour to see. What.
You know. Please about this one take
very little but if you could tell me how
important to the I I want
you to give up that So
a job saving it's ridiculous not because
I could spend the rest of my life when
you're not one might ask and
so much considering that it's
a very much sort of thing that I don't want
my future wife wasting her time enough
yourself last. I beg you to go to mother
already. As a boy has be a good to
a boy in them and come back tomorrow and
tell my mother I think about having all
those nations. See now how you
feel about it but forget it.
I'm sorry I didn't. I guess it's
just because I'm into tired it's
just that you stop working down at the
mission and Six-Pack of yourself. Do you
realize you're giving up your friends your
social life everything or was. It the
opportunity of helping underprivileged. You
should be proud of you for that region
. For working in the
power. Of the place for
a girl like you and that's why good
runs the place. What about him. I'd
like to meet him and. You and
Mr Wegg to come. Up to you.
And us out of the sea it's true I knew
there was another reason for you and Kyle
spending half the night down. You've no
idea let me use during the fun I have been
a man. Of mystery to me.
That you waited with.
Them. Do you really
believe that. Sure I do
go ahead and have all of on you
want you in your social work.
All. Ready to wake up darling.
Still having one of those horrible
nightmares again. The only thing
I can get you. To maybe.
Go back to. Shows.
Exam gentlemen. Professor Yes
like that's
a question if I may suddenly. About my
term paper I suddenly realise that I know
very little about real people. What gave
you that idea. You can't learn about life
cruising around. The I
was thinking of writing
a man thinks just before
he died. That the I'm
a scientific that's what I mean but with
your permission I'd like to change to
a paper feel qualified to handle it by
all means make that the subject like
a law professor.
Progress Report and you are
missing. It. When you turn in
your shield. And my share. Of the time
judging by the coverage you get on the
retard that. Led to the she'll be given to
you. Because you know your
first assignment but I do.
Good luck but I think.
Yesterday that I'd be working
with Frankie mills in
a high class just as each day brings its
little surprises I meet today to find.
Out and. We have a frank
is get away from here it's
a natural. To us smart
to figure all this out.
Sorry must be
a happy people. Back
up people back up. Back people to.
Really. Help their rock.
God to comfort me.
I CAN FEEL THE have wrath of the
public on my neck these crimes are
a disgrace to the city and
a menace to our citizens who have
to produce results or resign.
Chiefs on the warpath. We've got to deliver
the goods we'll all be putting the
paper. I want to buy research
from one end of the other yes.
The other Sure. How would you know slime
are you going to look at me when I'm down
on my luck. But you wouldn't like the look
made that I'm rolling in dough would you
say but see that. They are
getting very big on a
match. Mine answering
a few questions. Why don't you
run up and down forgive me.
Most I'm going to get
a few Yes I want privacy on the window but
you can try them out in the window in
the back. And make me look like a
tramp Madge not the one who like
a transient coming to my place this is
something I want to understand in the priest
crisis management how much of that do.
You want to rent or buy I want to buy
a chest custom I want
to thank you and find
a place. Thank
you. Richard I don't I think you
doing here. You give me away like.
That so now you know is this your idea.
Of to I want you to help me I'm going to
write
a term paper on the psychology of the
underprivileged underprivileged Why don't you
try the millionaire comes in with
a level to remember what
you said last night I mean
a lot of thought I think I just have
to move on I'll talk you making.
Fun of people as
a me and. Say this.
Battle as the folks announced the comment
out of there thought. Someone out.
What. Well I guess thank
you get brought up.
Out of your letter or
something. Come on let's get to
a clean table. Professor
what are you doing here
a big I'm. Going to say that you're not
Professor Brenner. I mislead you mistakenly
I'm.
A professor I know you when you play.
And I see it is useless and I think at the
best of them you might figure for the
same with nice to do some research on
your back thanks in that the people think
that I'm good and I need to give you my
fine don't worry about me Professor I can
keep
a secret no doubt about that but if you
both go for all so we will not be so. You
see me so that is I'm I'm conducting this
so that's the mission for the purpose of
something. That you had some wonderful
material you know I had. To like me to
show you how and they will
be great professors. That.
This is my five adults. If you will find
a load of valuable information I imagine
I could be going to that place. First I
would like you to meet some
There's an interesting cast.
Of.
The other. I want you to
know we saw them. Read
a lot of. This man is an investment study
in cycles of. I suppose you have never
met
a homeless I don't mean years
before. But you. Asked
bring them questions. I
didn't word it and. Ask if it
gives him pleasure to take human life.
To enjoy. Your people. Your.
Lake. Over here you could see
a perfect specimen of pizza place. Back.
If you like the best in him. If not.
I see you losing you wouldn't talk to
them. That's I should ask you your own
question. QUESTION The one you brought
up this morning the last two.
You see what she added up to once in
a muddy. This morning you wanted to know
what I meant things about just before you
that. But from time to pick you
said yourself you can't ask
a dead man but you can ask
yourself if so then. You must be
joking. Thinking you know it
doesn't joke. Do you think. You
can't be serious this is like
a crazy nightmare think. You have thirty
seconds plans of that question I'm
getting out of here. I'm
afraid not but then it's
a. Big. Please Professor what
are you thinking you're mad
insane I think so.
Your buck.
Our. Only. If you have them
and they knew compel you
to.
Do the. Time is one of only nine o'clock
I want you because Mrs Dennistoun
with you didn't come home at night and
the whole family friendly they thought
perhaps you might seem as if. You.
Wasn't listed in the dream and
mission trail that you did them.
Nevertheless is true when I call back
and you talk to. Them why she said. I mean
doesn't mean every night you've been
missing for years. Is excited over them.
I'm. Just. I just want to tell
you not to worry about which.
Yet you do research in the
dialect of children. All of
a. Hope you are so you are right the place
like that could possibly happen to him
down there. I don't think that's. Just.
Because according to Richard. So we did.
Welcome.
Young don't explain why he came to
a mission. That enticed me to
quit but I. Mean that's not
how well you know this fella that runs the
mission crowd way like. I do us because
Dennis and Frank e-mails were last seen in
Wagner's mission with the hero you don't
suspect that Mr Wagner had anything to do
with the disappearance I don't know but I
intend to find out. What it grew
up around to Mr Wagner right away.
Where are they doing that. The captain vigil
could something be done about it right
away by doing everything as humanly
possible this time. But I was wrong in this
case after and it's all right I'd like to
take time he was going up but when you
find him. That he
ready now.
Let him know. When he puti to do you know.
You see. This one thousand a tall
building. That the street from
a jewelry store just as
it was being robbed.
And happy. For me as
a president is off my. Back
then when. I was even less um I
wonder if you give me
a home address I get about information. I'm
Detective Crawford quickly check what I
want to talk of
a professor about the one of the students
Richard them all and what that meant not
given to you.
Thank you very much. I don't.
Know. I
thought you'd gone home there were too
many of the PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE YES they
just flat out times found it on mine. If
you see what they wanted they wanted to
talk to you about Richard then
I gave you your home address.
Whether that.
Was running Yes we'd like to talk to your
husband you can do what I'm expecting any
woman with
a piece come in when I guess. I
must protect the property and
this is
a fact it's not true and I'll be alarmed
we have nearly one question the professor
have I thought of it too. He
wanted to be seated like you.
It's. Just yet another
you say don't you think.
I'm some. Of the standard.
That's Carl Wagner down in the bog.
There's a printer Have you ever had
reason to suspect your husband of leading
a double life. To keep. My
husband at the same time.
That some of the half of. This man is
also known as Karl Wagner and he operates
a mission on the Bowery where Richard
Dunne of the most life thing. And we have
reason to believe that he's using the
place to cover criminal activities.
That he thinks is not
enough to some. And to him.
And those hurdles are not.
There in that there's been there will
have to take it to headquarters for
questioning. And. I'm quite willing to
go. Get my head cold.
That much all this is the proper time of
the printer home. You'd better prepare
yourself under-vote I've discovered that
Professor Brenner is none other than Carl
Wagner of the friends of mission.
That's right and we're bringing him as
a brother in for questioning.
Just. Over time so we've got
a runner and I think they are because
that's what I have to get that close.
There's
a runner. On this planet. That
I pledge to get. A role. If one is to be.
Look I only just thank you
thank you seem like my eight.
oh Oh
. In the studio what is this Where did you
come from I can't tell you that I know
I would kill me let me let him know you
will see it. Wouldn't hurt anybody
I know that I mean he just wouldn't
like it. Then you know you think
of that has to be I want you to do
the favor. You show me with my hand
that look you know the one that's what I
would like it. Like you want to do I want
you to get
a prescription pill for me when you right
away it comes in small. But he wanted
good for me I'm
a doctor I know what's good for me. I get
this deal you show me what's in there if
you keep it
a secret and therefore me
right away. Back. What
do you got. That. The sixty's all
the getting older made sixty
five sixty. Trying to make them I really
prefer from the two thousand while.
She was to be let out of
the trunk if. It's me and.
I break up again. That's all right you
just say we five thousand dollars.
Like. Don't you ever tell
a soul. See
it's to sell or let's go back
now let's find a deal it's just
a little closet where I can prove
that. It's only like when I.
Like that she likes it in that. Kind.
Of
a deal I can help you with going
out with you. Know. The bat. What
a prescription.
Colonel.
You must never see
a word about this. Why
have you allowed to come down here had
nothing to do it if I sleep right you. Did
you no harm and you tell me what
do you propose to do about. It
a little surprised you didn't tell me the
guy was in you just. So you know what to
do nothing. On time that you are
getting sentimental eliminate
a part of my record what you have told
why don't you let it alone she didn't do
anything. About you pull.
It Out the go but I gotta stop.
My few words around here.
That's why.
I know the very place that you hide where
no one will ever find you with me.
I prefer this for just such an occasion.
If you're the professor. And we'll be
married. And you can do your social
work anywhere with the power.
Six kids are able.
To do anything I say yes Richard. Yes.